[Musik]
unser gewinner der woche ist cristiano
ronaldo denn der hat auf instagram die
225 millionen follower marke geknackt
damit ist da die person mit den meisten
instagram anhängern der welt auf den
plätzen zwei und drei folgen sängerin
rihanna green day mit 191 und
schauspieler dwayne the rock johnson mit
187 millionen
schätzungen zufolge verdient ronaldo mit
insta werbung sogar mehr als durch sein
verein juventus turin
so soll apropos sting rund eine million
dollar bekommen mehr wert als jeder post
ist die liebe und diese woche feierten
gleich mehrere promis ihren hochzeitstag
youtube baby und ihr ehemann eugen sind
jetzt bereits seit zwei jahren
verheiratet
hochzeitsfotos schrieb sie auf die
nächsten jahre mein baby
ich liebe dich auch ann-kathrin und
fußballer mario götze hatten grund zur
freude
vor einem jahr fand die hochzeit statt
jetzt haben sie nicht so ein rom ihre
eigene kleine familie am längsten
zusammen sind anna und robert
lewandowski dass sportler paar ist seit
sieben jahren verheiratet und hat zwei
kinder
herzlichen glückwunsch an kathi hummels
sie hat einen weiteren erfolg im
gerichtsprozess erzielt ich bin
unfassbar glücklich und das sich gestern
am olg den prozess gegen den verband
sozialer wettbewerb gewonnen habe und
diesen sieg widme ich euch den widme ich
allen die spaß haben an instagram
weiterhin auch freie produktempfehlungen
geben wollen und hoffe dass ich damit
wirklich viel bewegen konnte dass wir
uns auch die influenza vor allem uns
mehr absichern konnten und das wir vor
allem gleichberechtigt werden wie eben
die printmedien und auch die fernseh
medien endlich ist mal wieder in
hollywood star in berlin und zwar
schauspieler keanu reeves es hier um den
vierten teil von matrix zu drehen
eigentlich hätte er zwei wochen in
quarantäne gewusst aber beim gesamten
team gab es dank negativer corona
testergebnisse eine ausnahme
trotzdem müssen wir uns leider noch
gedulden der film startet erst im april
2022 in den us kinos ist das niger
highlight des jahres nike bringt
zusammen mit dior den air jordan raus
die sogenannten
eher diors [ __ ] werden am 17 juli in
ausgewählten boutiquen und online
gedroppt der schuh ist auf acht 1500
exemplare limitiert und soll 2000 euro
kosten
im internet werden sie jetzt schon für
über 10.000 euro weiterverkauft gesicht
der kampagne ist übrigens rapper travis
scott weniger begehrt dürften aktuell
fleischwaren von wiesenhof und tennis
seien in beiden betrieben wurden mehrere
corona fälle festgestellt
immer mehr menschen stellen die
produktionsbedingungen in frage erinnert
auf die werbung von comedian kristall
nichts mehr an der meinung von starkoch
tim raue und der europa politikerin
sarah wiener
wir sind harte zeiten für uns alle und
das sollte uns einfach klarmachen was im
leben wichtig ist
ich denke dass auf diesem planeten vor
allen dingen jetzt und für die zukunft
klar sein muss dass der umgang mit
menschen der umgang mit lebewesen
fundamental geändert werden muss ist
kann nicht sein dass sich kilo fleisch
weniger kostet als ein kilo sie um das
zu ändern müssen wir alle gratulieren
[Musik]